- [Interviewer] So what
do you think drives you to
to pick up these girls more than anything?
What's your motivation to do it?
- I like hoes.
Yeah.
Because I don't have to deal
with all the other bullshit.
Of dating, I pay 'em or
I would give 'em dope
and they do what I wanna
do when I'm finished.
But now-
- [Interviewer] Do you find dating
a woman that isn't working the streets
a little more, more
headaches and more problems?
- No, I just I find it more
headaches, more problems.
And this is just easier, but everything
that's easy doesn't come free.
You know, this has driven me
down a road where soon as
I started doing cocaine
first thing I want to
do is go get a whore.
It's led my life into a turmoil.
And I keep thinking that I'm
going to find a good woman
but I have to understand
you can't change anybody.
And I can't change them.
And they do have good hearts,
but the whole street life
it's just a bunch of bullshit and scams.
I understand they gotta do what
they have to do, but it's dangerous.
And my addictions bought me there.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, and
your addiction is what?
- Cocaine.
- [Interviewer] Cocaine?
- Mm-hmm and sex.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, so that
combination leads you here?
- Yeah, lead me here.
- [Interviewer] How many
years you've been doing this?
- Well the first time I
picked up a prostitute,
I was 19 and I had a girlfriend.
I was just fascinated that you could
pay a woman money and
she'd do what you want.
So I ended up, I think it was down fed.
This was like back in say '84.
And I was rolling down
fig and I found one,
but I soon come to find
out that it's about money.
It's not a love thing.
It's not a friend thing.
I pay 'em, they do what I wanna do.
And they're out, ain't
no talking involved.
They don't give a fuck about what I say.
And I had learned that I shouldn't
give a fuck about what they say.
And over a period of time,
I learned that I don't give a fuck about,
well I can't say that because they
are people and they're good people.
And I try helping 'em,
but think about this,
when you're doing a business transaction
sexual transaction, it's it.
And you can try to be with them
and be a boyfriend with them or a friend.
And you'll come to find out.
It all just turns fuckin,
cause they're going go fuck
somebody else for money.
- [Interviewer] Okay, in a minute.
- In a minute.
- [Interviewer] In a minute.
- Who's ever got the most dope.
Who's got the most money.
That's where they hit it.
You can spend all day with a whore.
And soon as you run out of money and dope,
she's gone to the next.
And that's what they call bring trick.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And has
it gotten in the way now
of your relationships with
women outside of that world?
- Well, I'm educated.
So I know people on both.
I went to DeVry, have a four-year degree
in computer information systems.
- [Interviewer] What you do for a living?
- Right now I do IT work.
I got laid off.
I was working for.
Maybe I shouldn't said that.
- [Interviewer] I'll take it out.
Okay, and I was working for them.
But then I had a girlfriend
that had my child.
We started having problems
and she used sex against me.
So then I said, fuck it.
I started going out and buying.
- [Interviewer] What's
the craziest experience
you've had doing this?
- Well, the crazy experience
I ever had was where I was set up.
This just happened about
maybe a couple of months ago.
I was with this one girl and he said,
"Okay well I know where
to get some dope back."
I said, "Well, I'm not
going to spend any money.
I'm just going to smoke with you."
She didn't know, finally I said,
I said, what do you do?
I do everything as long as you smoke.
Took me over to a spot.
Next thing I know, my car got surrounded
and broke out the
windows and I punched it.
I ended up tearing up the
car, ran into a fence.
Chain link fence, caught
me like a net, like a fish.
And I'm getting nine staples.
- [Interviewer] I see a scar.
- And then being the way
I am, I turned around
and tried to go back and hit him again.
Yeah because that's the
world that you live in.
It's dog eat dog.
You got some ones that care
about some people, they're
people, human beings.
But then they'll turn on you in a minute.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, you
you've been arrested doing this?
- Never.
- [Interviewer] Cops arrested you?
What they call it, pandering?
What they call it?
Solicitation, no, never got
arrested for solicitation.
Because now the police
department or the law
they know what they do.
And it's like, accept it, they
know they're selling dope.
They know what the whole situation.
I guess they don't want us spending time.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, well, I mean
they're driving down Fig
and they see-
- They see it.
- [Interviewer] They know
exactly what's going on.
- And they asked him rouse,
sometimes rouse some girls
but what twist me out now it's
that the age of the girls.
And I'm just like, wow, man.
Because these women they're young and some
of 'em have don't know if
someone had been killed.
I know prostitutes that
were friends of mines.
But you know that on that
level, that got him killed
because they jack
somebody for their wallet.
The guy came back and killed him.
- [Interviewer] You've been married?
- Never been married.
- [Interviewer] Do you have kids?
- Yeah, got one 21-year-old.
Very proud of him.
He's in college.
He's about 6'4, 330, offensive tackle.
I pretty much raised him by myself.
His mother left us when he was one.
It wasn't behind no drugs.
And she just was a person
that liked to go out.
She moved to Atlanta work for a company.
So I had to-
- I'll take that off too.
Yeah, I had to change
the way I looked at it,
as far as raising the kid.
But still my addiction was there
and my sexual addiction was there.
But I was able to keep it under
control, now that he got 19.
I feel like I've done my job.
- [Interviewer] You're free.
- I'm free, but I'm not free.
The more you do it,
the more entangled into a spiral you get.
I don't know, sometimes,
I feel like I'm really just shooting dice
and one day it's going to come up grabs.
- [Interviewer] What are
you worried about most?
- Well, I'm worried about
me into it with one of 'em.
And having to defend
myself like just over in it
and then having to deal
with somebody else.
Because they always know
somebody because you know
they always know somebody.
Or they always try to
threaten you with that.
And you know, and it's
been a hell of a ride.
- [Interviewer] Do you believe in love?
- Yeah, I got hurt.
I was in love twice.
Both times I got hurt
and I never wanted to,
and see that, that's the other question
to ask me because that's
one of the main reasons
why I didn't wanna to jump
back into a relationship,
because I don't have to
love in this relationship.
There's just, you know what I mean?
You don't have to, I
don't have to love them.
I don't have to take care of them.
- [Interviewer] And I'm sure it changes
the way you see women.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] In terms
of how much you trust them.
- And why I see women
now on a different level
because even when I talked to way,
I see that they all can be a certain way.
It's about what they want.
I can understand, you know
you given your wife or doing things
for your wife and your girlfriend.
But in a way we're all tricks.
I'm just taking the easy way out.
- [Interviewer] Is your attitude that,
regardless of what kind
of relationship it is,
you're also you're still paying for it.
- It's so painful.
- [Interviewer] I hear that a lot.
- So painful.
But you know man, I'll tell you this.
I'm tired of it.
And I really am because
there's so much drama.
There's so much trickle
ration and so much bullshit.
That, it just puts you
in a situation where
aren't you tired of being sick and tired?
Yeah.
Now I know I got two out there.
And it's a certain type of pride too.
Because not only I don't
have to pay 'em money.
Sometimes I have 'em out there taking them
on runs where I'll take
them to the Fig, pick 'em up
take them back and forth to buy dope.
So I don't have to buy any dope.
- [Interviewer] You're
just hanging out with them.
- [Reggie] Hanging out with them.
But then you know lot of you
when you treat 'em like this.
They'll say, oh, I'll give you all.
I'll fuck you or give you
all the pussy you want.
But then me, I'm not that kind
of person where I'm very
scared of catching something.
So I kinda like touch them,
but I'm not going up in 'em.
Because I'm too old to
be catching AIDS or STDs.
And I've been lucky, very lucky.
- [Interviewer] Do you miss the closeness
or intimacy with the girl
or the little woman who really gets you?
- [Reggie] Yeah most definitely.
- Your personality-
- Most definitely.
A woman that knows you.
- [Interviewer] You have a connection?
- [Reggie] That has a connection with you.
- [Interviewer] Cause these are just.
- [Reggie] Yeah a woman
that really cares about you.
Cause talk is talk.
You know what I mean?
- None of these people care.
- [Reggie] And I miss that
because someone that you can talk
to that really understands
and wants to, and meet you.
And my mother father were
married for 62 years.
And you don't find that these days.
And I asked my mom
how did you and dad stay together so long?
She said, because we didn't
sweat the small stuff.
You know, young yet, but we let it go.
I mean, and it made
their marriage stronger.
I'm 55-years-old.
And I may not ever be able
to find the right woman.
Hopefully one day I will.
But if I have to change, I have to change.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, it's
great that you see that.
- Hmm?
- [Interviewer] It's
great that you see that.
- Yeah I have to change,
but I'll tell you what.
Soon as you take that, for me,
I don't know about everybody else.
Soon as I take that first hit.
I'm looking for a woman and
it's not just about sex things.
Just like having a woman
looking at her body.
Just being around it, even
though she's treacherous just
to have her talk nice and smooth to me.
- [Interviewer] So which came first?
The crack addiction or the sex addiction?
- The crack addiction,
but the sex addiction was always there
but it was undercover.
Okay. It was always there.
I was always looking, even when I was,
my cousin had told me, he said
I used to as a little boy I used
to go up and rub women's legs.
So I noticed that there was a difference
and I was like only three or four.
And I think I lost my virginity at 13.
And then, I mean, I can just, any woman.
I see any woman I don't care
if she's a whore, I'm bam.
I'm looking at her body and looking
at her because I love
everything about a woman.
Everything about her,
body shape is something I
don't care what anybody says.
There's something beautiful
about every woman.
She might be the ugliest woman around
but there's something
beautiful about it, something.
I guess that's a gift from God yeah.
- [Interviewer] Awesome, thank you
so much for sharing your story.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Very interesting.
Thank you for being so open and honest.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Thanks man.
- What my family gonna say.